foreign
[Music]
talking to yourself and that narrative
and just saying well I'm doing it for
the job I'm doing it for the job and
then it's like [__] man
where that that guy that you you know
and and with what you do you know it
it's it's like it really is it's like
you got to be the [__] role you got
to be the [__] role but then
well we're type A personalities right so
so we're gonna go in headstrong right
and Dive Right In but there's always a
price to pay yeah yeah there's always a
price to pay yeah yeah you know and and
I always say it's funny you say about
the excuse
it'd be so easy for me to say like when
I wrote the book that you know all my
actions and what happened to me was was
a result of you know working undercover
for all those years but man you got to
look in the mirror man you make your own
decisions and you and you live with them
and and so I look in the mirror and I
say you know whose fault it is that guy
right there you know that guy made the
bad decision and both things can be true
you know it's like yeah look what you
[__] did you know a thousand guns out
there you know it's like look at the
career look at the relationships look at
that you know on the front lines of this
thing you you know yeah um and and and
and again man like just God bless that
you can look at it now and look at this
sort of like Crisis that came in and
realize it that that it was probably the
opportunity of your life and it saved
you saved you saved your family you know
and and uh you know that psychiatrist
told me uh she said
you know with all the Betrayal you know
over these past two decades
that you've experienced she said if
there wasn't something wrong with you
I'd be worried [__] a yeah yeah you
know but again I I don't use I never use
any of that as an excuse man I made my
own decision sure and uh but you can
certainly see like you're saying you
know why you went down a path a certain
path based on what was going on you know
what all that should have happened if I
had stayed at the bank probably not yeah
yeah yeah yeah right right and and so
what now man like what are your goals
now like what do you what do you want
now what what gets you up in the morning
what makes you happy what what what uh
what what are you looking forward to so
the book has bought brought me so many
great opportunities uh it's got me on
the the speaking circuit and I got to
thank uh Steve Murphy and Javier Pena
the DEA narcos guys the two awesome
legends who brought down Pablo Escobar
because uh you know they kind of been my
my Godfathers in this speaking business
and gotten me in and uh I'm able to go
around at these law enforcement
conferences and I tell my story
and I love doing it and I love looking
out at these faces at these cops because
I can see
I can see the stress on their faces
right I see it in their eyes and I tell
them that the most important thing
right because what we do as as law
enforcement as guys we always put the
job first the jobs before our health
it's before our families always put it
first
I say just do this for me the most
important thing in your career is your
pension that's the most important thing
right
we're lucky because we're one of the
last professions that still have a
pension right and you have to live a
long healthy life after you retire
because you've earned that pension okay
now make the government pay you that
right so your goal and I always tell
them this is to get paid longer than you
worked right I worked for 26 years my
goal is to get that pension for 27 years
I love it you know so take care of
yourself man I know what you're doing is
so important right now in that case
you're on right now is so important step
back it's not that important look who's
around you when you go home that's
what's important those people you take
for granted right the family friends
that you're taking for granted that's
what's most important look at who's
around you tell them you love them give
them a kiss and think about your pension
yeah it's beautiful Yeah you mentioned
when you first walked in uh about Mel
and you know Mel's obviously a important
person in both of our lives but just
tell a little bit about what we tell a
little bit about uh a melchancian how he
came into your life so Mel chancy uh and
it's kind of funny because you know I
started to tell you that
there there was that old cartoon I used
to watch when I was a kid with the
Sheepdog and a wolf and they were they
were like mortal enemies right and and
all day they're battling back and forth
because the wolf's trying to get the
Sheep Sheepdogs protecting the sheep and
then at the end of the day they would
clock out with their time cards and and
exchange pleasantries and walk away with
their lunch boxes right because they
were okay and that's kind of like you
know ATF agents and outlaw bikers are
mortal enemies right I mean they hate us
we hate them right our our goal is to is
to lock them up in prison for the rest
of their life right and
so it's kind of ironic and funny that
melchancy who was an Outlaw Biker has
become such a huge part of my life you
know Mel has held my kids and and my
wife loves him and he's a he's a yeah
how can you not part of my family right
how can you not so
so he was brought into my life by by my
one of my best friends and my mentor
Chris Bayless who and Chris ironically
was went Undercover
uh with the ultimate goal of locking Mel
up yeah uh he now he went under Chris
went undercover in a different chapter
because he didn't want to be in Mel's
chapter because they had grown up in a
very kind of close to each other so he
was worried about little
cross-contamination
and and ultimately
um
Mel faced Ricoh charges
um so
in a weird kind of twist
chriser and Mel became friends yeah now
Mel went to prison yeah and Chris ended
up looking after Mel's mom uh who's one
of the sweetest ladies I've ever met in
my life while Mel was in prison and uh
staying in touch with him and uh you
know when Mel got out
there was a friendship there yeah and so
as when Mel got out chriser told me
I want you to meet this guy and uh
all I knew was Chris or vouch for him
that's all I needed to know right
because that's good enough for me right
and so he took me over to his house and
met his old Italian mom
um the whole scene was just kind of
funny yeah and and this was this was
huge Mel I mean he was the thickest man
I've ever you knew his reputation oh
yeah everyone was what was Mel's right
behind I mean Mel was so Mel was the
scariest Outlaw Biker who would ever
roam the face of the Earth yeah no
chance he was feared
um he you know Mel lived a brutal
existence violence and uh he was the
real deal and everyone knew of him
and knew he was not to be taken lightly
not to be messed with
um
this Mel we know now is not I call him
good Mel yeah badmil was a whole
different person yeah um and so you know
I of course knew of him and and you know
Christopher had filled me in on
everything yeah and and when I met this
guy this was not what I expected yeah
sure right this was this engaging
neighborhood guy but do you think that
man like dude like at me because again
you've you've
you've experienced you know it's like
you've been around
you know it's a big thing we always talk
about on this show it's like unless
you've been in the valley you you you
really can't know the [__] mountains
yes right like for sure and it's like
you sure as [__] can't help people like
you can't unless you've been down there
like you really can't reach down and
pull others out and and uh it's just
like it keeps on habits like guys like
you guys like male it's like guys you
know like
you you know he's really been there you
know oh yeah and and now it's like
devoting his life to to to helping
others is spreading Joy you know what I
mean and one thing that's easy to forget
about Mel you know because his Outlook
is so good on the Mel did a lot of time
in prison yeah you know between state
and federal prison Mel's done a lot of
time in prison and hard time a hard time
yeah because you know Mel was in it they
weren't putting Mel Chansey under
minimum security right right man was at
the Maxis right and with the worst of
the worst right and and you know I don't
know about you but I can't imagine
spending one night in jail yeah yeah
right yeah you know and this dude has
spent imagine years and years and years
in prison like how he could have such a
positive outlook on life is one of the
most amazing things about him yeah so so
I was introduced to him and
and and it was he was to me he was like
every guy I grew up with man he was a
neighborhood guy right you know I could
have been male Chansey right you could
have been no chance right he just he
he's another guy who got caught up in it
yeah he got caught up in it and uh he
was very good at it yeah and he rose to
the highest levels of his profession
yeah that's right and uh and and we we
just developed the same bond that he and
Chris are had I developed with him yeah
and the the funny thing was he knew of
the crew that I was working when I was
in Chicago you know he had dealt with
those guys and he knew of those guys and
and we just you know we just we just
bonded right away he came to my house
like I said he's held my kids I've been
to his house and and I saw in Mel
like this this not not just the
incredible story of redemption but I saw
this light in this guy I was like man if
this guy who's who spent like easily a
quarter of his life behind bars in
prison and and the rest of it you know
in this incredibly violent world
if he can see the sunshine through the
clouds so can I okay yeah yeah he has
been a huge inspiration too yeah yeah
you know a convicted felon
uh you know head of a motorcycle gang
Outlaw Biker yeah he's been one of the
biggest Inspirations in in the latter
part of my life that's beautiful man
crazy yeah that's beautiful I mean I
love him man
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's John
Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf of
both of us and everybody from the real
ones team I just want to sincerely thank
you guys for for tuning in the folks
that I bring on the show they're family
to me and uh being able to tell their
stories and bringing you into their
world is something I'm I'm just super
proud of and uh again grateful that you
guys tune in we've decided we want to
take things just a step further it's a
patreon community and basically what
that means is if you become part of this
community look I already board Bam Bam
if you want to become a part of this
community you're going to be able to
hear episodes early and all that ad free
and all that good stuff but there's all
this behind the scenes footage all this
stuff that we've shot that really brings
you into the folks that we've had on the
show really brings you into their world
live chats with me and the folks that I
bring on the show to talk about their
world talk about the issues that they're
dealing with but their triumphs and
their tragedies just go to patreon slash
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
was something about building bridges and
and bringing people together and
bringing folks that often don't get the
mic and giving the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tuned in means the
world anyways again thank you be good to
each other out there rock and roll